at all cause they just triggers me yeah
biggest triggers me yeah you know now
it's not a Vegas guy no well last time
would you and I were there oh you're
poisoning
did we that sushi remember that sushi we
ate and we both were like oh no I
remember no you don't know that's over
there really a rich guy with the girls
if you leave you're not getting the
money sure do sure do
I marry you and iron that was so strange
gaudy suite gone off some of these all
these gals are there and we're like it's
like one old guy Brian Mike's me this
thing goes hey this guy pay this much
money if you come any other thing
through with this old guy he's I was
doing a show for him you know this this
gaming thing and so Brian goes hey if
you come to this thing to they're gonna
pay for an appearance fee like yeah I
get hanging with Brian some easy money
man so I fly down for one night so we do
the game thing then we're all he's like
invite through into his room so it's
like so guy me Brian few other random
dudes and then a flock of young girls
and yeah I'm so awkward he's so we're
like I actually knew one from LA cuz
she's friends with a friend yeah buddy
of ours and I was like and then one girl
doesn't matter because if you leave
you're not getting your money whoa I
felt so yeah I remember you go I Maddie
I don't there's so sex traffic and [ __ ]
out of what that night now I know I I
felt so guilty having my mom I was like
this is wrong this is wrong I can't
believe I'm kidding well but you know
what it wasn't about the last time we
were together that's weird yeah I've had
a couple of those situations where you
get in there and you're with people that
you don't know that well and all these
girls show up I an experience like that
in Mexico where the guy was a Wall
Street guy and we're just all talking
and all of a sudden like ten girls walk
in and you're like oh boy this doesn't
this this is bad like these girls like
here these girls don't want to be here
everybody here's an older dude and it's
just [ __ ] gross like you're just like
who's somebody's paying these guys yeah
then you find
that there were we out there's a party
and there's a hot chick here I'm like
how do you hear she's I gather pay me
man like yeah I always feel like I don't
want to be that guy I don't want to be
part of that clique of dudes where they
look at me as a dude the old barnacle
with it's just gross and so that's why I
always lie about my age when I have sex
with them and it's very it's just a sad
see it's a sadly it's somebody's dog I
don't want to be right I don't want to
be pain I'm not paying for so there was
a video that went viral online back in
2014 of a man peeing on a cereal
conveyor belt
and he is currently being charged in
Tennessee for basically tampering with
consumer goods so he is yeah there's a
video of it that we have but he's
getting ten years in prison
ten years and there's a bit of him
peeing on the belt and this like we're
my lucky charms and Froot Loops if you
Bob
Kellogg's this is what happened back in
20 that affect me team taste it joke's
on you if they hosted it's fine yeah
well those are prey coming off the
toaster
oh hey set-aside sure I there's sure
that's a giant blackout of the huge dick
yeah it's both only I can't tell then a
wheat loaves dick it's gotta know he's
gonna get caught right why would you
film it though you would have got away
with it can you film it yeah but also
okay dude so you pissed on the Froot
Loops
Congrats they're still delicious and
milk yeah who cares yeah some people get
off on you think yeah it's like the guy
who came on yogurt samples yeah yeah say
he's handing out a frozen he's for a
hangout like old link like yeah like I
got Whole Foods or whatever it was I got
Ralph and he came on it and this woman
people were tasting it and a woman taste
it when there's come on that just come
on this was theirs come on this and yep
call the cops they did a little test on
it oh wow they said who is handing it
out you you know cops know right away
kind of guy who gets off on watching
people leave this come strangers
you sir come with us lady though oh
right away she went knows her cuz she
goes I knew right away I was caught you
know oh my god I knew her right away it
was semen yep there you go that guy what
do weird do what some people are on get
off on that they get it it's like a
sociopath thing where they like to watch
do you hear uh Pedro not Pedro my penis
but Big Papi got shot point-blank yeah
to make her a public better remove a lot
of STIs you see what happened the guy
who shot him I beat the [ __ ] see what
happened him I know who's seen the video
no oh there's video well down like this
it's just people just like yes common
yeah he's a legend right he's the
biggest horse ever Apple today know why
it happened do they have any Yankees fan
Oh hold on scroll up chin Ortiz shooter
play it you didn't see the video yet I
haven't seen this video no it's how he
shot him he ran up in a scooter or
motorcycle and then lapped him and shot
him they shot him look at the top of the
screen here that's Ortiz having a grand
old time dr k sipping on some beer
that's only good time someone walk it up
right now shooter
BAM and why did he shoot him they don't
know yet they thought it was a robbery
at first but it's not a robbery looks
like an assassination attempt he just
falls down yeah I wonder why they shot
him they have no idea
not yet now they're gonna find out let's
roll down and this is the public beating
the brakes off all of this one do you
think I really think he's gonna get away
after shooting the basically the [ __ ]
Michael Jordan of the dr do they're
gonna kill him
I want a Fiat you hate them we just
needed money like still enough he paid
him to do it right yeah somebody pay I
looks like that looks got hit well thank
God he's gonna be alright Jesus Christ I
don't like seeing this though you know
even though that's seen I like seein any
other kizuite I mean the Dominican
Republic has a very violent history I've
read a book about it what the [ __ ] was
that guy thinking very violent history
what was this guy thinking he might be
emotionally disturbed or or he just need
but is long wait but who's that that's a
different guy though no it's the same
dude really
God you know what broke my heart did you
hear Big Papi go don't let me dye my
hair man is I'm a good man Oh God but
they said they removed his colon his
lesser man intestines his gallbladder
but and he's gonna make a full recovery
okay that sucks to have no callin now
gotta take pills I'm gonna feel much
worse right much worse yeah Point Blank
could've been paralyzed I was just dead
yeah what's this or doesn't say he's not
a danger but he's heavily sedated and
will be intensive care for the next 24
hours
hey mister it's not it's no good it's no
no it's not you deafening effect his
quality of life down the road ah doctors
believe he'll recover quickly just point
blank in the back every thought he's
just gonna drive off we think should
happen like I think they should beat him
to death
I think he's be still life I want to
find out if he's a hired assassin I want
to find out that night was the worst
assassin on world he's on a scooter
that's the kind of [ __ ] where I go what
woods like somebody's wife you know you
were [ __ ] around some there's has to
be some backstory him in the dr you know
he's bases he's the face of the
mysteries of god there and you shoot him
there's the consequences you can't go
anywhere now so yeah who knows so he got
he got a stiff a [ __ ] his stooge to do
it
oxygen or was you know who knows I don't
know I can't wait to find out
yeah it's something something they have
to find the dominican information out of
this young man yeah just one stay out of
the dr lady see what happened in
american there just died and then we are
psych mmm they had bad heart and america
us well no i thinkin work for us
dr cazuela this one was having hard
issues on medication there you know we
know that that's not the reason they
died so we get the talk theology report
then we'll be able to find out take
seven weeks though but the dr goes nah
man they came here on their own they
just died it was nothing we did yeah
suspect somebody gotta keep my ass here
yeah thirty times while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gift it's a gift it's a gift